[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans livres et vous
votre nouvelle émission littéraire qui
par des livres pour aller vers vous
cette dimension morale au fond de la
loyauté
on n'utilise que dans le côté négatif il
tua était déloyale au moment de la
campagne présidentielle
le mode 2d des loyauté est venu très
souvent on la voit il a été déloyale
mais mais au fond la loyauté on ne sait
pas très bien l'approché parfois on a on
a des rêves c'est le titre ii du livre
on a des rêves pour soi même qui sont
pas tout à fait les bons mais à force on
finit par faire le tri tous ces
personnages en fait dans les rêveurs
sont des gens qui auraient pu passer
leur temps à rêver leur vie où arrivait
une vie meilleure pour eux mêmes et
finalement quand même y arrive à trouver
leur place
livrez vous c'est sur public sénat
[Musique]